Hello, welcome to this week's LWIAY YouTube's favorite show hosted with me
And me
YAYYYYYY
Leave your entries in the subreddit Bros
And I'll watch
submissions in the next episode of LWIAY
(clapping)
(more clapping)
500,000 likes. That's all it took to force Marzia to be part of this video
Yeah, thank you I'm so happy to be ...
Do you know what we're doing?
Kind of...
I mean I watch your videos, but they all become a big blur after a while
So...
What do you say? LWIAY Youtube's favourite show, roll the intro:
Leave your entries the in the Subreddit...
Predictions, what do you expect to see?
Marzia: I mean I'm reading "HMMMMMMM"
Ok, you can't cheat.
Marzia: If Brad doesn't do a HMMM right now on me, I'll be upset
Attention, the androids' LED it's the "I'm not a robot" symbol. (Together: HMMMMMMMMMMMM)
Hey look its you!
Marzia: How about Marzia hosts LWIAY, Pew News and Meme👏 Review👏 for a week,
While PewDiePie makes food, reviews fashion, and does makeup.
You already do it.
I do literally everything in this channel.
Marzia: Off camera.
Oh? What?
I like how they just want me - - you to replace everything that I do
I mean, they're tired of you, I get it.
What do you mean?
Record themselves playing game which millions of people are doing;
Considered original content.
Yes, preach it!
Reacting to his fans memes; not considered original content.
WOW
My 9 year olds, I am so proud.
That's the thing, like, you're just playing a game.
It's not your game. Nothing, nothing has changed.
I have always been unoriginal.
Ok you read the firsh one, I read the...
Marzia: Firsh one?!?!
Making a meme in English so Felix can read it.
Marzia: Fare un meme in italiano cosi che Marzia lo capisca.
Making a meme in Italian so Marzia can understand.
Make a meme on russian to make fun of Felix
woof woof woof bark woof edgar woof
Marzia: Maya is not happy about this.
Hey look that's awesome!
Marzia: That's really cool.
You get the best fan arts.
Marzia: Yeah I really do.
No one takes this amount of time for me. They'll just say they took 20 hours or 50 hours.
Together: AWWWWWWWWWWWWW
Marzia: That's very cute.
This is so cute, can we hit 5000 likes on this video?
Marzia: 5000?!?!
Well, you lowball them and they'll be like:
Oh meh gawd can we weawwy do it? And then they're like:
Look how many we got.
Marzia: Wow.
They're 9 years old. They don't know what they're doing
Marzia: Writing memes in English so Marzia and Felix can both understand them
Marzia: Scriverli in italiano cosi che possa capirli solo Marzia e sia lei a doverli recensire
Jesus Christ!
Skidlididdidididi
Oh my god!
Thank you!
Marzia: I feel like a sneeze will be stronger than a fart.
You haven't seen my farts.
Marzia: I've heard them.. and smelt them! So, yeah.
So you know about the power.
Eating a picture- oh wait! He did it, he actually did it!
Marzia: So you have to eat him now?
(That's what she said)
Damnit. Next video, I gotta save that for next one. I'm sorry. I will do it, well done!
Thank you for not dying. By the way. I really appreciate that.
Marzia: I used to eat paper as a kid.
Marzia: Coz I thought they were like cooler chewing gums.
There you have it everybody.
You're culturally insensitive (Casey)
Logan
I'm vegan now...
Marzia: That was so good.
I wish I had that card.
Marzia: 9 years old
Marzia: Marzia hosting LWIAY
Brad Marzia
Marzia: PewDiePie
Marzia: So the expected Brad right, but I'm here.
Who's saying you're not..
Marzia: HUUUUUUUUH?
Oh no, they want me to do a let's play with Lego Star Wars.
Marzia: Let's do it together, off-camera we can play it.
I'm down to play with you, but not for the 9 olds.
(D E M O N E T I Z E D)
Okay, moving on...
Celebrates 10th Birthday
Marzia: Oh nooooo (RIP)
You gotta do what you gotta do. You gotta grow up, it's part of life.
Okay.
PewDiePie.
Red Pewdiepie.
Green PewDiePie.
Pink Spaghetti-
GUYS
This is a real whamen. She's not spaghetti.
(Marzia in background: So disrespectful)
That is racism. And I will not tolerate any racism against my spaghetti girlfriend.
Marzia: Thank you, thank you. <3
Marzia: Woah!
That's pretty good.
You know what? That's really good. I don't know why I said pretty good. That's really good.
Marzia: Wait what?
You guys suck, like, I really thought you would-
Marzia: Is that actually Logan Paul?
No it's not.
It really looks like it though, that's why it's funny.
Marzia: Yeah, I thought maybe it was actually him.
Marzia: At first I was like what?!?
He went through a weird phase. We all do it, there's no shaming in it.
Marzia: "Marzia, Welcome to LWIAY." Thank you very much.
How does it feel?
That's pretty much everything on this channel.
Marzia: Yup *laughter*
Hm?
I don't get it either. ()
5 black blocks 1 white block :)))
Up your game Pewds.
God Dayumn
That's a lot of those things.
Are you diagnosed with ligma?
Marzia: No, STOP
That has to be fake.
You don't get Ligma-ed by someone and get Saw Con -ed back
You did it to me  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
You asked me and I said what''s Ligma
Did it work? Yeah
GOTEM
Noticed our waitress had an accent. I asked where she was from and she says I'm Russian
I asked her if she knows what my hat says
Oh he had it!
She says that's a curse word
She knew exactly who PewDiePie was and wanted a picture
This is so wholesome and sweet
Can we buy a PewDiePie Slav merch that doesn't ship to Russia
Thank you guys
oof
Don't judge me okay, I get enough judgment from these guys
Undress Alice
Wait what?
Oh ok,
For some reason in the game there's an option to undress this eight-year-old
Did you do it?
Did you know?
clapping was invented by Dr Felix Clapjellberg when he tried to awkward handshake with himself.
(Couple Laugher)
That is you
I mean it makes sense you know
Logan Paul versus KSI
Poppy Harlow vs. Gloria Borger
That's what we need everyone want me to fight
it's kind of like clapping you know
Animal Super Squad (out now)
I'm done with this pass the mic to Edgar
It's like they're complaining this is what they do they just complain all the time
They want the old outra back. We want the old PewDiePie back.
How about watching older videos (mind blown)
No, that's ridiculous
See? Now I'm on their side
Judge: you're sentenced to death for the murder of four children
Logan Paul: I'm vegan now
Get the cuffs off this man, he's free to go.
Did Brad actually make this? Yeah he did
Youtube: Become Original
I hope you're good at the game.
Okay, we have three more memes how old is PewDiePie 28 years I have three more years
Wait, what do you mean three?
You don't have anymore...
2 more years
Not even, you're almost 29
As Marzia is in LWIAY I'd thought it would be cute if she reacted to this:
Do you wanna put on the headphones?
Aww
So she said it's okay if I show a couple pictures
Soooo
Is that a cool transition probably not. Here she is, she's cool, beautiful, funny
everything
and
is that weird?
Yes and her name is Marzia
I remember that. (Agreeing hmm)
Yeah, I think I'll keep it at this
Yeah
I remember that video
Did you like it?
Yeah, I was happy that you showed me
Showing me but at the same time, you know
I didn't know anything about this YouTube thing
I didn't wanna be
You didn't even have a Facebook. yeah.
I mean I only opened Facebook so I could reach out to you.
Stalker...
One upvote = Felix has to learn one Italian world
Marzia: You know plenty, though
I don't know 22,000. Well, I guess I'm learning Italian.
Ciao, bella Marzia, Como tu va bene
They- they are all Italian words but they don't connect
Yo volio un pizza, Marzia?
Thank you, fo-
Grazie mille, per guado...
El- la, una videa
Marzia: Il video
Pewds: Il video
Punio das like...
Buttonno
What are you trying to say?
They understand
Clicca mi piace su questo video
Yes, that's it thank you
Thank you Marzia for hosting this week of LWIAY with me very nice 👌
Okay, bye
PewDiePie with the 6-0 win
Taking over YouTube
Tryna get like him
Brofist to the face
Can you keep up with the pace and I'm never gonna switch, but can you do this?
How's it going, bro?
Got together like this when you want to hit a flow grinding like open up up and the top
I'll never stop run up in the city and I'm never gonna flop tell me when to go
I'm like whenever I'm done with this pass the mic to Edgar
Stalling
Is that 10 minutes?